than Shapiro at her in chief of the
Daily wire syndicated columnist and
hosted than Shapiro show what do you
make of this I mean obviously it's a
it's a good day for the country when the
next Nazi gets deported and it is sad
that there are so many prior
administrations that fail to do the job
President Trump is very bad at being a
Nazi I think you know there's so many
folks on the Left who keep accusing him
of Hitlerian tactics and he's just like
a Nazi he just deported one the last
remaining one that we know of inside the
United States and that's a pretty good
indicator that at least he takes this
sort of thing seriously surely and you
know I I don't know that it's it could
be a coincidence but it doesn't seem to
be because yesterday the president
hosted in the East Room of the White
House the salute the heroes event all
about the ice agents and then this
morning we wake up to the news that ice
had deported this last known Nazi I
think it's all part of the narrative
that the administration is trying to
present to voters before the midterm
elections look this is a choice election
you have got either the Republicans who
are strong on borders they like ice
versus the Democrats who some want to
abolish it and are soft on borders no
question I mean this is certainly part
of the president's main appeal he's been
tweeting about it all this morning and
he's exactly right I mean if you look at
the Democratic party platform right now
they're moving steadily in the direction
of an anti borders party that doesn't
believe in the the existence of
something like ice and the president
understands that you do actually have to
deport some folks and you do need a
border border enforcement authority
otherwise how exactly are you gonna
protect the citizens of the United
States both in terms of current citizens
and also in terms of the character of
the United States when people can get in
and by lying about their Nazi past and
then stay if you don't have anyone to
deport them so you have Ortez Ortiz here
in New York who was successful the 28
year olds who you've been trying to get
to debate and you have Elizabeth Warren
saying crazy thing in Gillibrand saying
abolish ice but the ones they're
successful in the special election for
the Democrats the ones that almost win
and close the gap and others like Connor
limb that do win they don't talk about
why a wild Left strategies they sound
almost like Republicans Ben so where do
you go from rhetoric Andrea rhetoric to
reality it's a really interesting
phenomenon to watch as the the rhetoric
of the Democratic Party
taken over by the radical left wing of
the party well the people who are
winning in a lot of these districts are
people who are more moderate Democrats
if the Democrats were smart they'd
embraced the sort of moderate platform
but they're not going to do that because
the base is so active and they're so
interested in appeasing that base at
this point they're really afraid of
alienating Millennials who don't know a
lot about border policy or cared a lot
about border policy and that's leading
them down a pretty electoral e front
path I think all right then this was a
shocker an awards show got political
last night VMA Awards watched this Club
you never know what's going to happen at
the VMAs
I mean beefs pawpaws bad language people
run to the bathroom and send out crazy
tweets it's basically like the typical
day at the White House and your face
Trump I'm looking at this like it's game
day people but do not worry because at
this games you guys are allowed to kneel
you can do whatever the hell you want
there's no old white man back in stock
I never support my girl
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so Ben what was your reaction
that you had logic who's a rapper he was
wearing a t-shirt it's lame in the
border wall and all this the family's
immigrant families were joined together
when the when the the wall goes up yes
so much courage you know much courage it
takes to be in Los Angeles in front of a
group of cheering people who hate
President Trump and chat about how
terrible Trump is and how terrible the
wall is the levels of courage that I
mean exceeds a Normandy it's just
incredible to watch all of these brave
and courageous individuals who are
millions of dollars selling records to
millions of Americans talk about their
leftist politics in front of other
cheering leftists who will undoubtedly
congratulate them at the after parties
where they get thousands of dollars in
swag so thank you let me just ask you
this for Kevin Hart in particular he's
in New York City at Radio City and he's
gone out of his way and to be one of the
most successful comedians and
entertainers in the country and everyone
tie every time someone tries to get him
politically always backed off he says I
want to be positive
what happened what do you think changed
what's the I mean do you think he was
winging it to me that seemed very
intentional no it's definitely
intentional it was I'm going to make a
headline tonight and I have to virtue
signal to all the people in the
Hollywood community in the New York
community that I am anti Trump president
Trump has basically become the moral
litmus test for a lot of folks on the
left and on the coast which is why
Michael avenatti who showed up the VMAs
yesterday I wouldn't count him out as a
presidential contender in 2020 for the
Democrats simply because he fires up
their base and the only thing that
unifies the Democrats right now
apparently is hatred to the president oh
yeah there's plenty of that to go around
certainly well and again the VMAs it
just demonstrates the the elitist nature
of the Democratic Party and the elitist
nature of left right now all the people
in the middle of the country who are
worried about their jobs who are worried
about manufacturing who are worried
about the issues in their towns and then
are being scorned by the folks on the
coast they're not looking at that with
with the sort of kind eye I think a lot
of Democrats think they are Hillary
Clinton tried this in 2016 by trotting
out Lena Dunham at the DNC it didn't
work then but Democrats seem to be
doubling down on what took them there
you really think Mike avenatti is a
legitimate contender for the for the
nomination I don't see why not I mean
the fact is that he is seen as the most
anti Trump guy in the room and if the
Democrats underperform in 2018 I don't
see why there wouldn't be a backlash to
embrace somebody like
not even spends all of his time simply
dogging the president he's busy at that
all right Ben thank you very much for
joining us from the west coast thanks
good